okay mr. push-ups let's hear your story
chicks dig me what you inside because I
really were underwear and when I do it's
usually something unusual
go ahead no I can't sounds like you got
at least two people in there already
I rather of you uh homosexuals you mean
like flaming or think hard
what is circle closed ah get a little
tired of this tell me what you think of
this is it a star it is a star a
ring-a-ding day so what are you doing
here I'm just trying to give you your
money's worth
you paid top dollar for me wow I think
you're a bargain you're probably right
you're incredibly head-over-heels in
love with me obviously hopelessly deeply
in love with me yes what do you say you
and I get out of here
go someplace quiet I think I'll need
that the more you know who you are and
what you want the less you like things
I'm saying
I was sleeping thanks for that Roxanne
what after tennis is a friend you'll
never be good if you don't know that you
are
give me angry you've had a bad day
you're cranky good good who angrier who
you scary me salary as men may save your
life when he stays you understand that
then again maybe one of us won't we've
been going about this all wrong miss mr.
Stay Puft is okay he's a sailor he's in
New York we get this guy laid we won't
have any trouble where the hell have you
been soldier army training sir you need
to defend yourself are you getting
Motown oh damn you small haven't noticed
yes so is Hitler
what's a horrible comparison
we Came we saw we kicked its ass who is
your perfect guy he's intelligent
supportive funny hmm
me Nick is tall is this true
yes it's true this man has no dick for
relaxing times I've shown him how the
world works in work get paid you drink
make it Suntory time I'll be out back
I'm going to find a tree to chop down
you